et
bonjour bienvenue dans votre émission
montre moi un signe ça va
tous les jours des entendants et des
sources croisent et ne communique pas
je vais vous montrer les signes pour
rétablir la communication et l'améliorer
bonjour madame sy qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour vous vous êtes sourde
d'accord
e
enveloppe
en veulent à
cette personne n'a pas compris la
communication n'est pas clair le signe
ces colis petit ou moyen
j'ai une idée je vais essayer de m'y
mets simplement on va voir
coli
cody c'est ça d'accord
merci
au revoir à bientôt oui bien sûr des
sourds peuvent regarder des films
par exemple je vois des gens qui
pleurent qui sont tristes l'amour tout
ça j'observe et parfois je comprends pas
tout mais dans l'ensemble je comprends
l'histoire une amis m'appellent et me
demande tu as compris d'histoire qu'est
ce que ça raconte alors je lui raconte
que c'est juste
la poste un timbre une enveloppe un
colis envoyé la famille la métropole
au revoir